all right hi CNN here's our panel he
host ESPN's first take in the Stephen A
Smith Show podcast Stephen A Smith is
over here and he's a comedian comedian
writer and producer whose new series Ted
is streaming on peacock Seth McFarland
is over
here and the Democratic congressman from
California Adam schf he's going to be
the senator from
California
okay all right here's what people want
to know what are the panel's thoughts on
the jury award oh this happened just
before we went on the air the jury
awarding egene Carol 83.3 million in
Damages in her suit against Donald Trump
Donald Trump what do we think not good
right this was the this this was the
this was the suit that he got threatened
to be thrown out of uh several times
right like how toxic do you have to be
where you're too rude to be on trial for
sexual assault
right I think it's uh I think it's true
Justice uh the only thing he cares about
is himself and money and going after the
money is a is a way to bring about some
real Justice do you think he did it yes
I do you do you think you think he raped
her in Berg Goodman yeah you think he
raped her in Berg Goodman I have no idea
here's what I will tell you it means it
means absolutely nothing doesn't mean a
damn thing and and I get tired of people
trying to act like it first of all the
man is running for president of the
United States and part of the reason
he's running for it is because he's
getting those campaign dollars so he
pick up the money to pay for his legal
bills that's what he's going to do it's
not he's not going to lose any money
secondly it ain't going to be 83.3
million he'll appeal it it'll get
knocked down and I'm just getting tired
of seeing so much stuff targeted in his
Direction but somehow some way he still
survives I mean we're talking about a
situation where he's still going to be
the GOP nominee he's still going to be
running for president your president
Bing that's the individual that you're
going to have to beat four indictments
91 counts they even bringing up the
bankruptcies ain't even bringing up this
particular issue with this civil case
and somehow some way he puts cats to
shame because he clearly has more than
nine lives I mean come on you know you
come on you you bring up the the most
perfect disparity between these two
people it's like he cares about himself
he cares about money and you have Joe
Biden who put forth the the inflation
reduction act which contains climate
Provisions that are going to probably
bear fruit long after he's gone mhm long
after he's gone abely what does he have
to gain by that nothing except uh God
forbid I use the word altruism yeah well
you know look um I don't I don't share
your pessimism about this or your
pessimism about the general election the
reason why Joe Biden is going to beat
Donald Trump is because at the end of
the day America is going to want a
president who is a decent human being uh
who doesn't who doesn't on other
people um who
has has some uh interest in the American
people some interest in something Beyond
himself I think at the end of the day
people are going to reject this this
bigoted divisive figure uh they're going
to they're not going to want to put the
country through they have they have
every time except that one
time no really I mean he didn't he
didn't he he really lost every election
except the 2016 and that of course he
didn't really win that one either I mean
he not the popular vote right and also
you know I don't know whether he did it
but I don't put anything past him I also
think bergd do should have better
security has
there has there been uh any point in
history in which not to say it's a cult
but has there been any point in history
in which the same candidate has been put
forth three times in a row three
elections in a row by the same party
three elections that's a great question
three elections in a row um it could
have happened with who's the guy Teddy
Roosevelt but I guess well Roos
Franklin won four elections in a row so
there you go yeah but you know given the
circumstances well there's always
something going on in the well no really
you can't do that you can't be like well
there's a war on you we have to stick
with me I mean that doesn't work
depression stick with me lost a popular
vote in both elections but the bottom
line is this I respect the fact that you
don't share my pessimism I truly do I
understand where you're coming from but
I think that's part of the problem I
think the Democratic party should share
my pessimism I think they should be on
high alert I think they need to to treat
him with the seriousness that it
deserves because you're you're have you
having a lot of faith in the American
people the man did get over 74 million
votes you've got people that are looking
at Joe Biden I'm not going to call him a
cognitive mess or anything like that
that's very disrespectful I would never
speak about our president that way but
when you're 82 years of age it's not
it's not offensive to say you're no
longer spring chicken and you don't seem
to have the level of VI and and energy
that you want you to have so you take
that into consideration you take that
into consideration you can't ignore the
fact that this man is a threat oh make
no mistake I take him as serious as a
heart attack okay um I I'm optimistic
but but we're going to have to fight to
the nail and one of the biggest
obstacles we're going to have to
overcome is all the efforts to prevent
people from voting okay uh we're going
to have to turn out our people uh we're
going to have to work like never before
we're goingon to have to work like our
democracy is on the line because it damn
well is right and and I don't so I I
take this as serious just interject one
thing into this discussion about Trump
that we've been having all night it was
a question I was going to ask you we
were in out of time sure the Atlantic
put out an article last year and it was
called separating Sports by sex doesn't
make sense right and talked about how we
separate sports like the wnb and just
because it's just
socialization this is insane I agree
okay that's why people vote for Trump M
because there's stuff like that on the
left that people just go uh I know
Trump's horrible but separating by
Sports by sex makes perfect sense and if
you think it doesn't uh you can't lead
the country that's cutting off your nose
despite your face okay I'm just I'm just
giving you the answer to the question
you're asking all night long why do they
vote for Donald Trump it's not always
because they like him it's because stuff
like that is cookier to people and
there's lots of it's cookier than
trashing the capital what the it
think
I think in a way it is how is it's it's
apples and oranges it's apples and
oranges one is more evil one is one is
more horrible but thinking that I mean
what would happen if we combined the
WNBA and the NBA please was well LeBron
would go from average in 25 to average
in
70 because half the team I mean you mix
it up and he'd hold the ball and create
the mismatch take you're both you're
both right and it's I I'm G I'm going to
tell you something like I I when you
donate to the Democratic party which I
have you get to do certain things and I
I got to I didn't even get a thank
you I I got on a I gave I gave him a
million dollars twice I didn't get a I
got on a say thank you thank
you I I got on a zoom with Biden for
like 10 minutes or you can you can talk
to Biden for 10 minutes alone like okay
great wow that was AI
Biden that was not
yeah trust me it wasn't AI Biden um but
but the the what I took away from that
was that oh this guy is not the world's
greatest public speaker but I'm now
getting why people like Lindsey Graham
are defending him and saying like if you
don't like Joe Biden there's something
wrong with you which you can look it up
he did he did say I'm paraphrasing
because I've had a 100 drinks
but but he did he did essentially say
that like if you don't like Joe Biden as
a person there's something wrong with
you you need to look in the mirror but
there's a flip side and here's the flip
side you can like Joe Biden but hate
Capitol Hill as of course as as is as it
has been for so many years when you look
at people and think about Trump you ever
watched Trump debate this is why I was
joking around and said I challenge him
to debate what would I have to worry
about he doesn't say anything you he
goes up against Democrats it's going to
be very very good it's going to be
fabulous see he hasn't said anything
right and
nobody nobody on a democratic side has
what is it the pizzazz I know you got
the substance but you've got a lot of
people out there that are preoccupy with
their own lives and they want somebody
that knows how to ingratiate Deb is
called
a g when you disseminate so much
you're like biffing Back to the
Future getting dumped on by the
doesn't work if you think Trump doesn't
say anything during a debate you should
see
well now you tell
me if you don't if you don't think
Donald Trump says anything during debate
you should watch Steve
gar in a debate you can't defend
yourself against an onslaught of lies
and where you have I just said
we're on
CNN what is what is I'm on Fox what's
the difference I know but we're not
supposed to swear really on CNN
no you're going to lose this gig for me
we got to
[Applause]
go